i i feel like girls shouldn't be hookers
and shouldn't be homes but like you need
them
do you know what it is i think they have
their place in society yeah on a real
one like i feel like they have their
playlists
don't get me wrong i would never
encourage anyone to go into that
profession because on a personal level i
just think that the emotions the
spiritual trauma all of that stuff is
deeper when you're having to deal with
so many different types of people
even if it's like physical or mental
like it really
it it can get bad for you
i know but
like i just someone's gotta do it
someone's gotta do it it's kind of me it
couldn't be me
that way could it could it be me but
like like i'm just saying someone's
gotta
and you know what
yeah i just i think hookers are needed
into
i would go to church and say this
i don't know about that faster oh
god i would i would look it and like the
pastors can say what they want but half
the time the pastors are the ones that
sleep with everybody you basically are
the homemaker
you're the one that's making the house
i i caught i can't comment on that one
because me i don't know i'd like to
thank my pastor ain't doing that but if
that's what he'd be doing then damn
and then basically these women in the
church are married to the pastor because
they go to him and ask if they should
date this guy
you might as well be their husband and
then you got all these single childless
women in the church they're basically
even if they're not sleeping with
basically his concubine
i don't want to hear [ __ ] from this
pastor for real
and they're taking money from these
[ __ ] they might as well like the
pastor is literally just another version
of a trick i swear to god because these
women will be homeless because they're
spending two to three hundred bucks a
week right or 100 bucks 50 bucks
whatever it is when these women only
have one income so they're on the track
to be homeless because they didn't save
2.5 million for retirement
you might you might as well be a pimp
pastor
sounds like a father oh
oh
hams are a type of father yeah not for
real the girls that don't have one that
find them hey these girls got daddy
issues they're trying to solve them look
at it look at look at it i'm just saying
the pastors i swear to god they're just
another version of pimps to be a show
the pastor is just another version of a
trick
[Music]
i swear to god that is not within your
niche
i swear to god like
you are going to hurt feelings and
is it because i'm making sense
i'm kind of making sense hey
you're triggering people
look but religion
religion is
about as close to race as you go get
like that one is a
if you thought politics was bad religion
look at i i would consider myself a
christian yeah but
i mean this these pastors be [ __ ] the
congregation i don't know what to tell
you
they've been doing it for years
they women like a man with power and
these men with power can't turn down
women
look at can you blame them most guys
can't turn down women that are just
flocked at them i don't blame the guys
but you're kind of a pimp
you're the homemaker yo it's tough stuff
in these streets look at it look at i'm
not
i don't hate i don't hate you she said
[ __ ] i'm not knocking him but like do
what you're gonna do sir
but
while you're doing that i'm trying to
build families
no
and you tell these women then it gets
even worse because they're like oh only
date within your church or only dating a
guy that loves god as much as you do
these men don't love god as much as
women do
come on
hey some of them dude
hey that is the exception though i can't
lie
the one there's like a million [ __ ]
for every one dude okay let's start
there half the time these guys are only
in church to find the wife even though
the wife has been ran through like let's
just be honest hold a minute ain't it
the other way around don't you think
half of the girls are in church to find
a husband i think it's yeah they're both
there why do you think people they they
get in their relationship and they leave
i've got a question for you then yeah
like my concept is
a man's goal is to sleep with as many
women as possible to spread their seed a
woman's goal is to find the highest
valuable man that they can find
would you put into context would you
what would you say to the idea that
women are in church or are in places to
marry because men don't want to be
locked down oh okay well they found
comfort in it but they don't want well
two two there's two options one they go
to the church because that's where the
hose at
it's a double whammy yo
you go somewhere where there's five
[ __ ] for every one dude
and let's be honest half these girls are
born again virgins which is just a
mating strategy oh i've been ran through
but let's make this guy pay full price
yo what are we doing what to the
brothers that i know pay a full price
let me see
let me
oh but i was so bro oh my god and then
they talk about oh i was so broken that
was why i did that [ __ ] shut up you
were horny shut up
and then you have the chastity speakers
they encourage this in the church
because they reward hoes they reward
hoes because they tell hoes you can do
whatever you want then you get baptized
you can just find a husband like that
and he'll forgive you oh let me let me
encourage the men yeah wipe up these
hoes no wonder [ __ ] love church
no wonder [ __ ] love church
yo
so
well speaking straight facts here
hey no lie was told
so yeah like
and then the no wonder the men are
leaving they're like this is nonsense
i'm going to church and the girls are
[ __ ] in the church than not at
church why am i even here
oh wait the [ __ ] are there oh okay
oh and then they're born again virgins
but then the next year
they'd be back on the streets y'all
they they say that uh the streets are
seasonal
yeah uh winter is coughing season yeah
then they move into spring
yes get your body right ready for summer
back in them streets
to come back to winter
back in church yeah it's tough so the
game is the game
it's a it's a mating strategy that's
what women do they try to increase
their
value oh i just had one girl cancel this
is why yeah
who's ago uh the german girl
uh okay
just do another day
um that's but no wonder [ __ ] love
church because
guys don't get with this [ __ ] guys like
they kind of do sometimes if they marry
a hoe
like and then the worst oh and then they
reward okay they reward these [ __ ]
even more
because because what they'll do is
they'll say on top of this let's give
you a platform let's give you a
microphone and tell the girls how you
did this host [ __ ] and found a husband
so they're marketing hoeness
that's what they're doing with these
chastity speakers and it's always the
[ __ ] it's always the [ __ ] you got ran
through and always the dude who waited
how did i donate
[Laughter]
it's always it's always the [ __ ] you
got ran through i'm sorry it's it's
never the guy and she's always broken
what the [ __ ] just call it what it is
[ __ ] look it you you met mr tall dark
and handsome like you were feeling them
that's like you're human it's okay oh
you've got a lot of ideas here man
right us two yeah we hear what you're
saying but these hoe like what are these
hoes do so then the church is like on
top of this let's give her a platform to
talk to other women and mark it being a
house preach
get the hoes out of the church they
don't belong here
what happened to the days when we would
turn people down
trans people no you're not allowed in
our church why would you be allowed
you're gay i'm sorry there's places you
can you can worship wherever but not in
this church what the what about refugees
and you rebecca
you you sucked off the whole football
team no you don't get to come here
how are they meant to change
what how they meant to change how are
they meant to change how are they meant
to be forgiven by god like repent from
their sins change their ways uh-huh like
how they meant to find their way into
heaven if we
get rid of them look at they can find
their way into heaven but if you got a
kid by two different baby daddies like
don't ask the next guy to wait for you
just sleep with him ho
yoho stop acting like you're not home
shout out to the baby mom's giving up if
he's trying to if he's trying to wipe
you if he's trying to like it's but
you're making him wait you're making it
him way when the last guy's got it for
free
big facts
lady what are you talking about
shout out my brother's getting it for
free too
and who's your brother the pastor
that's not my brother that's a father
that's the father we look at that one
and we go yes fatherly
it's always the pastor
now now don't get me wrong
there are some pastors i'm like look
i get it
but you're the homemaker you're the
homemaker and then they get on the stand
and they say you're forgiven well of
course you're gonna preach forgiveness
why because you want the hose
you imagine he's probably again you're
forgiven looking at his wife like yeah
i'ma see you
when you come to repent
on your weekly visit yeah your wife your
wife coming up to you oh yeah um i'm
just going to take uh groceries to the
pasta
like he's why these times he's eating
them groceries
i feel like i feel like this would be a
great i i feel like this would be a
great show
oh
i can't lie uh i go to church and this
i would get
if i was yeah i don't even know don't
bring me to your church i'd be a great
pastor
i keep it real look at it
i i keep it real
platform
becky becky what is this what's on your
instagram i thought i thought you got
baptized why are you posting pics
hey
paul you're speaking facts here but
right now the world don't the word ain't
trying to hear it i mean youtube might
be trying to hear it
oh but no
you'd do this for no money wouldn't you
you just do it on a separate channel
for no money and no is it like no
monetization
if that i don't know
i basically did youtube for free for
like two and a half years
two years why why was that because i
didn't make money no is it because you
didn't know how to or was it because you
were just building up the following
building it and i made a lot of really
stupid mistakes
so it was like both
but
i was stubborn i wanted people to like
me for me and like be able to post
whatever i wanted yeah but that doesn't
really work on youtube okay so um i feel
like you do that on instagram though
um somewhere
my instagram's a little more random
because
like but not not really lately it's just
been about the show yeah that's true but
no before old content yeah well that was
also when i was doing random [ __ ] on
other stuff but then i like i've only
kept it consistent for like two months
and it's blown up i'm like why didn't i
do this the whole time
but but
yeah no i i think even if i didn't have
a microphone i would still give my
opinions unwarranted i like that
i've just always been the [ __ ] that
gave her opinion but nobody asked
nobody asked maybe they'd be looking at
you like
oh wow powerful that this hurts but no
nobody asked but
i just don't like people that like
that's i here's the thing i feel like
i've always been somewhat religious i
grew up catholic
i i went to bible study like twice a
week for two years but i just couldn't
get past the we're marketing being a hoe
my monkey and being a hug like crazy and
that and the worst part and they just
say [ __ ] that feels good like i feel
like a more honest conversation is look
i got lucky mostly because i'm hot yeah
like like if i was like the chastity
speaker right i'm the girl usually the
[ __ ] is hot let's just be honest
and usually the guy only pulled her like
because
he's religious and she's like a little
bit out of his league okay so that's why
this man's willing to wait because he's
like there's no way and on god's green
earth i would have pulled this [ __ ] in
like normal time
like jason christina ever do you know
what i'm talking about
they're they're catholic i understand
yeah yeah so he's like fine i'll wait
and you know she's she's chill too i'm
sure he probably likes her whatever
whatever but
i'm like like if i was a chat like this
is what i'd be like look at some [ __ ]
get away with it because you know
they're they're pretty okay you get
pretty privileged in life some hoes
look at look at what's her face michael
b jordan's [ __ ]
yeah look it she screwed every rapper
like yeah you know that like future like
she was hooking up with all like all the
rappers like that's what she's known for
i was getting ran through and she's
still got michael b jordan why she's hot
some [ __ ] get away with it not all
[ __ ] are created equal do you look
like lori harvey no sis do you look like
the chastity speaker
no it's not going to work out for you
so if you're if you're average looking
and you're a hoe [ __ ] you're going to
have no one waiting for you sierra
sierra literally there's a future
god knows what's going on there and then
she ends up with russell wilson a
religious man a great advocate
someone that you look at and you go you
look up to that kind of person he's a
nfl football player leads the seahawks
yeah well because she's hot some people
get away with it because they're hot
just like some guys get away with [ __ ]
because they're hot there's hot
privilege
but you're gonna tell me you found
yourself after you like that's what i
never i was so broken i just hate this
i remember listening to these chastity
speakers and hi
raised my hand and being like so you
want me to wait but you got ran through
by like everybody you were saying
and you still got a husband
you're marketing being a hoe
you know what i've seen i've seen it yet
where
one like girls are like they've seen one
of their friends getting married
and
they are in like tears
and like most people are looking at it
like why are you in tears but me i'm
looking at her like you're in tears
because your friend did what you they've
told you is not possible
go out be a hoe and find a guy
wait and you think that's why their
friend's crying look like the friends
are crying tears of joy to be like oh my
gosh like my friend you did it yeah
some girls only dream that
after their home phase they'll be able
to
cough something i'm gonna be honest most
girls can i'm
yeah i'm sorry a good brother like
i don't know
look at i mean
it depends what you define as good and
what like it depends what you're meant
that's like financially stable like they
they're
like respectable i don't yeah
yeah
yeah like most girls yeah i mean it
depends how bad of a whole face but i've
asked you guys this question so many
times would you rather girl have slept
with 20 dudes you'll never meet or one
dude you know every guy says 20 dudes
i'll never meet all [ __ ] has to do is
move
me all [ __ ] has to do is move
one guy i know like oh it depends like
no but like me because i i i'm like i'm
in a place where it's like oh
all right you said to him i now know
cool i get it
if there's 20 guys i don't know
this [ __ ] will walk me into a room and
make me greet brothers that she's done
business i said i said you never meet
you never meet him
yeah yeah you know i don't know no you'd
never meet him
never meet him
i could see that one that's a tough one
yeah
every guy i've asked
20 guys i'll never meet you i wouldn't
be okay with that i'll tell you why
though like because i understand that
like the more a girl has sex right
the more she starts to find herself in
her own body the more that most men
won't be able to
like
uh what do you call it
they won't be able to make her feel
things like that like the last guy did
like if she's had like 10 guys
one of them was like a
it probably broke her heart like he's
probably doing like a madness
how are you ever going to live up to
that well this is this is what i say i
don't
the number matters but it matters for
the wrong different reason okay it's not
about it's not about the number it's
about the like she can't view the last
guy as better than you
that's true like because otherwise guys
she's gonna who who is alaska so if if
she lost her virginity to like chad from
like like he'd like like six four man
super successful he broke up with her
i'm sorry it's over for you i don't care
if that was the only other guy
okay like it's about it's about like she
can't view you as settled
she can't she can't feel like she's
settled for you you have to be like the
best she can do yeah otherwise then it
just needs to cheat and disrespect
not even cheap but the disrespect yeah
she won't be able to look at you as a as
a man or the figure or the head of her
household yeah because she she wants the
last dude
like women are compared a lot more than
men that's why social media [ __ ] us up
so much
he does because i mean i mean i'll look
at a guy like shout out to him
i wish i was there
move on with my life girls will
literally look at other girls and go
wow
i need to make changes oh my stomach
isn't this all right cool lipo like
not that extreme but like no that's yeah
yeah like girls compare more
so
yeah they will come like yeah yeah if
you're not the best she can do like
look at she's it's not gonna be a good
marriage like i think me from now on
yeah the heart that that's insecure i
wouldn't even do that but like
would it even be a thing if like guys
were like oh so like who's your ex
well i don't think i would ever do it
but like now like we're having this
conversation it's like something i'd
even think about just to know where
where you was yeah
but you can you can tell if a girl if
you're a girl's first choice
you can tell by the way she treats you
that's true like if she like i'm sorry
but if you're if like
glad this isn't live because there are
certain guys i wouldn't want to hear
this message but if you're if you're a
girl's first choice like
like she she literally will do like
whatever you want like she'll be
obsessed like obsessed i i i figured
that out yeah
like it doesn't even matter you could do
anything at like
anything she does not care because you
like you she's like you're her first
choice
like and you've seen it you've seen like
that girl that got cheated on
yeah and she's staying you're like why
why why are you saying because that that
is her first choice she doesn't think
she can do better
and it depends like what is she looking
for like what does she value and it's
different for every girl so you don't
know like what might be typing attention
it might be money
well but girl it's probably status i bet
you i bet you that guy's cool and he is
he look liked by people yeah yeah
because that's like more attractive to
girls than anything it's like being
liked
like we want a guy that is like liked by
other people
that's why like friend groups are so
important for guys but like like yeah
like i i want to see like who are your
friends
like what what do you what do you like
how do they treat you like how do you
interact with people like it because if
if if i see that
like your friends think you're lame or
your friends or whatever like it makes
me like like not as attracted to you but
but guys they don't care
yeah like who your friends are like they
don't give [ __ ]
like they don't want your friends to be
hoes i think like that's a turn off
but yeah but like do you care like if a
[ __ ] is liked by her friends if she's
like the popular no actually i'll be
like if my girl's not like closer she's
falling out with her friends all right
come let's go home yeah don't worry
about it you don't want to figure out
yeah you don't care
yeah
but
and so that's why like i hate the word
alpha and beta but i know like what they
talk about because it's like the guy
that she views as alpha
but it depends
yeah so
i kind of figured out that like
it's not to say
this extreme ends of the spectrum
if you're leaning towards one that's
better i don't think it's ever going to
have both
or like be say oh i'm in the middle i've
got alpha traits and beta trips
i think you should be leaning towards
either side of the spectrum but it's
quite sad to see that at the extreme
side the alphas are telling you
this is how to be out for you have to do
this you have to do that and it's like
bro it looks like you have oh [ __ ] sorry
what's up
oh i have to get people no worries
what's the time
okay